you factored a squared minus B squared
which is a difference of two perfect
squares and you factored it like this a
plus B a minus B but now what we're
going to do is we're going to factor the
sum okay which means you're adding two
squares two perfect squares and the way
we're gonna factor this is a plus bi
times a minus bi now look what happens
here let's do an example first and I'll
show you so let's say we wanted to
factor x squared plus a hundred right so
if we use this formula right here you
can see this should factor as X plus 10i
okay X plus 10 I times X minus 10 I
right okay now let's just double check
by multiplying these together so if we
do the distributive property we get x
times X which is x squared x times
negative 10 I which is negative 10 is
and then if we distribute the 10 I we
get plus 10i X and then we get a
negative 100 I squared okay now I
squared you know from previous videos
and you know from your classes so far
that I squared is negative 1 so we have
a negative 1 times a negative 100 is so
positive 100 here we have x squared and
we have a negative 10 iakhs and a
positive 10 acts those are cancelling so
we're left back with x squared plus 100
so that's the key if you know the
formula you've got it's basically
recognizing that you have a perfect
square plus a perfect